hi i'm sierra capri and i play monster
hi i'm brett gray and i play caesar hey
what's up
i almost think that i'm sorry i'm brett
gray and i play jamal i'm jessica marie
garcia and i play jasmine i'm julia
macias and i play oscar spooky diaz
i'm diego tanoco and i play cesar diaz
and i'm jason janelle i play ruby and
we're here with buzzfeed and we're going
to play who's who
who's most like their character ah
no that's not real no
i would say jason
jason jason you know what though it
changed like because remember last year
we did say yeah yeah he's not jamal at
all you're not jamal absolutely jason
has more bites than ruby though yeah
he's not gonna play well jason
yeah he sure is to all of us shout out
to all the kids okay who's the least
like their character
julio
there's not a thug bone in this
julio should turn something back in and
he doesn't like
who's most likely to get caught liking
an old picture of their crush on
instagram diego there you go have i ever
been caught liking somebody's photo yes
of course and then you you don't know if
you're like you should unlike it or not
so you don't like it but you really like
it because you're like i'm already
caught i don't know
you'd rather have two notes
hello twice
who's most likely to break character uh
brett
i only got one take yeah
can we do it again
can we do it again really quick
who's most likely to forget their lines
jason
i don't forget i'd be stressed
you'll have a scene where everyone has
monologues and all his line is like yeah
maybe and he's like
what is it
what was that these are lies these are
not lies they're laughing because it's
the truth that's why he's so natural yes
he's right
because he doesn't think that he's not
thinking is he surprising himself
who's more likely to dance or sing on
set
we don't shut up
all day every day the ep
singing so you don't mind yeah it's
fantastic yes it'd be an emotional scene
and then all you hear is brett in the
back singing
and you're trying to cry
okay who's most likely to fall asleep on
set oh okay you know you know what
i don't know i don't know about you
but i didn't fall asleep not one time
that's a lie
who's most likely to hit up crap
services jason all day every day
he knows what the hot snack is before
anybody else he's like he knows
but the lemon isn't enough he puts fruit
in the water yes
yeah it has to be infused did you know
we're getting a pizza truck on the 19th
who's most likely to need advice after
getting caught in a sticky situation
all of us yeah we all kind of lean on
each other we all lean on each other 100
yeah and sierra and i have like a i was
about to say a language where we don't
even speak together
the front row right here is a nest
who's most likely to show up late to set
with a cup of coffee not with a cup of
coffee but wait
sierra um what time did you get
i'm sorry
30 minutes later
didn't get anything said to him i'm 10
minutes late because you know my hair
takes a little longer absolutely
all of a sudden i'm holding production
you don't want sierra apologies it is
diego
literally i i show up jacob's like i
don't know because i don't have hair
baby
i remember i was one time i was like
dang i was late diego was like oh i was
like 40 minutes late
yeah diego always does one up you when
you're late but
it's like the smooth
yeah
who's the most street smart he's from
philly i was about to say i say jason i
remember one time we ordered it really
jersey it's the it's the east coast
who's the best at doing impressions of
their cast members right we're waiting
okay i'll do jason and cesar in a scene
together here we go here's ruby i just i
wait wait what is it okay
[Laughter]
i've given you everything
okay and then diego's like
say
don't do this
i'm not good with the game i smell emmy
who's least likely to respond in the
group chat no everyone but me and julio
yeah you're very responsible the four of
you
diego's the very worst no you are the
very one yes i've been good lately
thanks everybody and make sure that you
watch on my blog season 4 streaming now
on netflix
[Music]
you